all right jessica
jessica where'd you grow up where are
you from born and raised in los angeles
california
and tell me about your family you grew
up with both your parents
um no my mom but at 17 i left
because me and her fought all the time
so
i was on my own since 17. okay and um
i finished school and then kind of just
it went left from there how was i was
like what kind of kid were you in high
school
i was good good kid the childhood was
okay
um any abuse i wouldn't i wouldn't say
that my childhood was okay because i was
with a single mother that was crazy
um but uh as far as school that was my
only getaway
so i was good in school but when school
was over it was kind of just
me you know by myself and i never really
had any like
um and like
it's you know like instructions with
life like no one's ever like told me
what to do what not to do so i kind of
just
went with it myself and of course it
wasn't
the best yeah so after you left home
with where'd you go what do you do
um i was i've been on the streets for a
long time i mean
every now and then i'll kind of pick it
up and then i'll go back to drugs and
alcohol and then i'll go back down
you know so when did drugs and alcohol
come in the picture um
i would say like after high school yeah
after high school yeah i got into
cocaine and the people i was hanging
around
um they were no good so you know i
started like
smoking marijuana and cigarettes and
um a few years after
i got into crystal meth and um
yeah okay and alcohol alcohol is my
biggest problem
is alcohol number one it's been my
biggest downfall
for my life okay what were you doing for
money after you left mom
um well i started stripping and then
um being in the strip club you know i
met a guy and he told me he would pay me
more than
average you know if i came with him so i
went with him and
um then i opened up to prostitution
from there because it was more money so
like on the street or yeah on the street
um online just however you know i could
find someone there's a lot of online
stuff yeah and a lot of times i was
using a strip club to find
guys because that's the easiest way you
know sure um
so yeah like i got into that lifestyle
um
and it was no good like you know like
it's that lifestyle is very very rough
wage did you start
stripping um i was 17. 17.
yeah and i started like
escorting and prostitution i would say
maybe um
it was like right before i had my son so
i would say like uh
like 20. like around 20. i started
um getting around and then i moved to
vegas
and that was the biggest downfall that i
had
at all of life because vegas is nothing
but prostitution and stripping and
pimps and just all of that um
so yeah i was in vegas
and times got tough out there
um so i started you know getting into i
had this guy
and he uh he was a pimp but
he didn't label himself as that he
labeled himself as like my boyfriend
right but he was like pimping me i guess
if that's what you want to say
and i i don't know i've just been very
vulnerable my whole life so i kind of
just go with the flow
and uh yeah i just
um he would like he started like putting
his hands on me and stuff
and it became like visceral visual
visual
to like where you could see it on my
face and my lips my eyes
like he'd be beat you up yeah okay so um
i thought that was love so i dealt with
it for a long time
but um after so long you know i kind of
like left him
and then i was just on my own um for the
most part i really was like
doing these things because i don't have
family so i have no one like i literally
have nowhere to go so i have these guys
they're helping me so i just dealt with
it
for the time being um
and um yeah
um yeah so that's that's a lot that has
to do with my homelessness
and you know just me kind of just
allowing to be used
because i have no one you know i don't
have family
i don't um have no family
like absolutely no one like i mean your
mom is still alive my mom's alive
but she's just her we've never really
got along
my dad he's left us when i was six
um do you have contact with your mom
still yeah i have contact with her but
we don't
we can literally be with each other
maybe a day
and after that it's like we just start
fighting and i just leave
um and no siblings yeah i have brothers
and sisters but
they like we all kind of do our own
thing we're all older now so we kind of
do our own thing
they stayed with my mom um when i left
at 17 they were with my mom they stayed
with my mom
um and uh
yeah now they're just they just do
whatever so after the vegas
so yeah after vegas um i mean i was just
in and out of jail
i had a lot of like um
cases on me for like just because i
started like getting into alcohol really
really bad so then i started getting a
lot of cases
with um being publicly intoxicated
or uh being found on the street
passed out because i drunk so much like
waking up in hospitals not knowing what
happened and they're telling me that
they just found me on the ground
um yeah and so after
after so many times of being in jail in
vegas i just kind of came back out here
and then when i came back out here
i gave a few of my family members a
chance
and um he [ __ ] me over
and i ended up back in jail um
over an argument that was uh
it was really petty and then i guess
after so many times of being in jail
the judge is was telling me you know
like if i want
to live my life and not be in jail i
have to get a job so
you know i went got a job and um
i mean i'm working now but i'm still
homeless i'm still sleeping in cars
you know and sometimes it gets even so
hectic that i have to
sleep in like a 24-hour laundry mat
so yeah so you're homeless right now
yeah and where do you stay
i just kind of stay wherever wherever i
can
like right now i currently sleep in my
cousin's car
when he goes to work i just i just i i
got like a membership at planet fitness
so i could have somewhere to go and
shower
yeah but um in what neighborhood do you
tend to sleep um like englewood okay
englewood area um
and yeah i just
this is just a life i have to live i
have no no you know i mean
my job is like the only thing that i
have
you know i have my son but i don't you
know he's with his dad so
where are you working now um right now
i'm working at a pizza place
okay so stripping and escorting is kind
of
um i mean it's it's not
i mean i i don't want to get back in
trouble but i do kind of still do it you
know
as far as stripping it's a little
different out here in los angeles so
i like it's like a job now so like i
would have to sign a w-2 and everything
so i don't really do
that but as far as like prostitution you
know what
i mean it's still there when it's needed
it's needed always you know
yeah i don't really have any bills
luckily you know but
disturbing stripping in vegas is
different than stripping an l.a yeah
streaming in vegas
you all you need is um your
um sheriff's license your sheriff's card
and once you get your sheriff's card um
then you could just work
and you get paid whatever you get paid
it's it's
like free hand out here um you have to
sign
like an application and you work certain
amount of days certain amount of hours
you get paid hourly and they take
everything they take all your money from
you out here
the only money that you take home is
your tips which is nothing nowadays
because there's so many girls out here
so kind of like
gave the you know the strip club a break
and i mean
prostitution is just easier you know for
someone like me
so it's just you know
so you have a daughter no i have a son
you have a son
and and where is he he's with his dad
his dad yeah
so you're kind of without any family
yeah do you have contact with your with
your son yeah
i talked to him yeah i don't i don't see
him as much because i don't want him to
see me like this
you know but we talk
he's old enough now to like call me and
he has a phone so he'll text me
right but um but yeah we don't i don't
really see him as much
as i should because of my situation
yeah what are your plans and goals do
you have anything
um i do i i really want to start a
cleaning business
um i've been saying this for like two
years now so i need to like really get
on my feet
so i can start it but um
yeah and then also like i really love
cooking so i do want to open a
restaurant
you know long-term goal my short-term
goal is to start my cleaning business my
long-term goal
is to open a restaurant so yeah
and then what are the upsides and
downsides of sex work
do you find it uh like you get depressed
after doing it for a while or
does it affect you personally or yeah
effective does it affect relationships
um you said sex no sex work i mean like
whether it's stripping your sex work
yeah
i mean yeah i don't i don't have any
friends i don't have any family
um
it kind of messes it a lot up i mean not
only that like my
my alcohol i have a really really bad
alcohol problem so that
just messes up a lot in my life
no one wants to be around me does
drinking make the
the sex work easier to do oh i feel
disgusted
before it during it after it i think
i'd never stop thinking about it it's it
i hate it like
but it's just it's just like i just feel
like it's
the easiest way to not think about
things
you know not think about my problems and
get money as well
yeah so you know i just
deal with it it i don't like it at all
like i'm not happy
i'm not proud of who i am it's just kind
of
you know i get i just see it as a part
of life i try to like
stay humble and just do what i have to
do
yeah do you think your childhood
kind of set you up for definitely for
this
kind of life i mean i just like i've
never like
had anyone you know like i don't i don't
know if you
understand what i mean by that like i
don't have anyone
so i just kind of feel like i just do
what i feel like i should do
and i i'm very vulnerable i listen to
whatever anyone says so
you like you can make this much money
doing this and i'll just do it you know
what i'm saying
and you think that maybe comes from not
having a dad around that
would give you the role model or the
guidance or the maybe
i mean as i get older i'm starting to
realize that that might be the reason
i never really looked at it like that
when i you know before
um now it's kind of like maybe that
might be the reason how old are you
i'm 29 29.
how's your your son he's he's seven
seven yeah he'll be eight this year
and your relationships with men or
you've had success or
no no not at all um
i don't know i guess i have like a smart
mouth i just have a lot of anger in me
so i guess it shows and a lot of people
don't want to be around it
so a lot of times with men i just it
doesn't work
and then with friends i just it never
lasts
yeah and then alcohol probably yeah the
alcohol problem just
it's just like the the cherry on the pie
is just it just
makes everything worse yes
do you feel like the relationship that
your siblings have with your
with your mom is something that you envy
or wish you had
i mean yeah of course i've always wished
i had like had family
and like just like i always wish i was
loved
so yeah my mom i don't know why she like
chooses
i mean i kind of know why she chooses to
like
pick them over me you know because i i
mean we get into it all the time even
when i was young we've always
argued and had problems but
like she's like still to this you know
in these days like
she's still just really like she just
like she hates me
she tells me this all the time and she
hates me she wish she never had me
um she always favorites them
um she helps them out you know she
doesn't really help me
i'm her oldest i don't understand why
and maybe that's why
because she feels like i should already
be good but
i was never taught to be good
so i don't know where to start and it's
like
everyone tells me like you're older
you're grown you should know
better and it's like you don't
understand and like it's hard to know
better
because you don't know i don't know i
don't it's like every time i think i
know i'm wrong
so i'm just like stuck
what was the uh the lowest point in your
life
um now right now
what was the best part of your life um
[Music]
i would say and
i can't nick i can't answer that i don't
know i've had a really
tough life um it's like every time i
think
everything's good and something else
happens yeah so i i don't know i don't
really have any like
happy happy times in my life your
childhood was not magical
no yeah it was horrible so
i don't know was there any abuse child
abuse sexual abuse abuse anything
yeah i mean child abuse no sexual abuse
i guess you could say that like mentally
physically yeah
mentally yeah um but what kind of sexual
abuse
um i mean
um
i mean i guess like the whole pimping
thing i would say
kind of i mean because he claimed to be
my boyfriend you know we were having sex
everything was like we were together but
i was having sex with other people
yeah for money so um
i felt like
i should go have sex you know i should
go have sex with him
so i could go have sex with others to
get money i i don't know i just really
wasn't like
uh aware you know i thought that that's
what i was supposed to do
yeah and this this was in vegas yeah and
was was he like a violent
pimp or a i mean do you intimidate you
i did i didn't think he was until he
started putting his hands on me
it was kind of like i was just already
in a situation so i just still i just
dealt with it
um but uh
he doesn't come off like he's a woman
beater but yeah he was
like more like maybe like months into
the relationship i started to realize
like he's crazy
he doesn't care about life he doesn't
care about anyone but himself
yeah yeah i was i was definitely
scared to i'm sorry let me ask that
because
otherwise it looks like he's like where
are these voices coming from
yeah when you would bring him money did
that make him feel
does that make you feel like he loved
you yeah all right so
let me ask that then so uh did so were
you scared to leave
that relationship yeah i was scared i
didn't know what he would do
if i left because i was making him a lot
of money so
and he would always say that like you're
never leaving me you're never leaving me
and so um yeah but you would
ask yeah just on the floor as well but
you would
bring him the money all of it yeah
every single penny you give him the
money
and he provides what he just provided a
house and food for me and like
maybe he'll buy me like clothes and
stuff
but i gave him everything and
um i just feel like
i don't know i just like at the at the
time it kind of just made me feel like
that's what i was supposed to do it made
me feel good like
here you know especially when i came
back with a lot of money i was really
happy like here you know
he was happy i was happy yeah so it
worked
did he provide you with drugs um
i mean marijuana i the whole drug thing
i did on my own
okay yeah so um and alcohol was part of
your
life then yeah alcohol is still part of
my life it's
still messing me up i don't know i mean
i know i should go to a.a
but i'm it's just hard i can't
i just can't walk into the building i
don't know why i just can't like
i won't let myself until you're ready
until i'm ready i guess
it's like i'm tired of
waking up in hospitals and and all this
dumb things
all the stupid things that i've done but
i just don't want to give it up you know
i don't know why i just don't
i feel like it's like a band-aid it like
helps me get over all the things that
i'm going through like
if i was sleeping in the car sober i
would go crazy
but if i'm sleeping in a car and i'm
drunk i'm fine
you know so it's more so just
um it's just like oh it's just my exit
out of life
i just try to like exit everything out
and i just rent alcohol
that's really really bad right now like
i've lost everything
do you feel like if you had a little
more stability in your life if you had
housing or
something like that you might be able to
have a better chance of getting clean i
just
honestly i pray i just hope for a
miracle
that's exactly why i mean i feel like
maybe if i had support i probably would
it would be easier for me to go to aaa
or you know
[Music]
get over my addictions but um
i don't and i don't i don't like want to
beat myself up for that
but i do i can't help it
how bad has it gotten i've checked in a
hospital
saying that i want to commit suicide um
i've had a lot of suicide thoughts i'm
just not strong enough to do it
um it's just hard like
like i have zero confidence like there's
no confidence at all like it's hard for
me to be like yeah
care about yourself like do this for you
like i'm so used to doing for everyone
else
you just have to give yourself the same
care and love that you give to
those around you i'm trying
it's so hard i just don't know where to
start it's like i hear that all the time
but it's like
it doesn't change quickly it takes some
time and effort
i really hope so because i feel so
hopeless right now
it's like i do have friends that tell me
these things but
you know it's like i i feel it you know
when we're talking about it but
when i'm like by myself i'm back to like
you know like the regular
so it's harder when you're alone yeah i
don't like being alone i go crazy when
i'm alone
and um yeah i just
i don't know i i really i just i don't
know like i feel like i don't know what
it feels like to be loved but i do have
people that love me but i just don't
feel it and i feel like i don't feel it
because i don't love myself
so i i don't know it's just hard
like i i don't know like it's like
people think i need a a but i just think
i need maybe like
counseling or like a therapy or
something maybe i need to talk to
someone
you know to figure out what it is that
um that i'm doing wrong because every
time i think i'm doing something right
and something else comes and i'm and i'm
doing it wrong
so yeah i just knew i was gonna cry
because
like this is not something that i i talk
to people about you know
kind of needed this
yeah all right thank you jessica